bonsoir nous sommes le 30 juin 2015
dernier numéro du 7-8 politique pour
cette saison numéro consacré en grande
partie aux élections régionales mais pas
uniquement dont soir kate chanabé vous
êtes élus de la majorité à
montigny-le-bretonneux 11e adjointe
déléguée aux affaires économiques aux
affaires générales à la vie étudiante et
au marché forain mais vous êtes invités
ce soir car dans l'eau quelques instants
aux ailes en cours vous lancerez le
groupe des républicains de saint quentin
en yvelines
alors pourquoi un groupe spécifique les
républicains sur saint quentin
ça va servir à quoi alors je suis
également délégué du canton de montigny
non montigny comprendront signé
guyancourt voilà donc les républicains
de saint quentin en yvelines c'est
vraiment une idée toute simple qui avant
tout une initiative militante donc c'est
une volonté de fédérer le militantisme
sur le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines
voilà donc briser les adhésions de créer
une cohérence une cohésion tout à fait
tout à fait en fait il s'avère qu'on a
beaucoup de militants sur 51 ans ni
ville et que ce travail a été accompli
depuis toujours un travail de terrain et
on avait cette volonté de mettre en
cohérence de toutes les actions à
l'échelle de la de l'agglomération
combien d'adhérents alors au niveau deux
du saint quentin en yvelines historique
on a à peu près 500 adhérents là ça va
s'élargir aux désignations peut-être
caméra sur la scène commune qui arrive
donc à ce niveau là on aura ils sont à
peu près 300 donc on est en tout à peu
près 800 alors quel est le profil si on
peut dresser le profil du militant saint
quentinois ils sont jeunes moins jeunes
sur des militants et des adhérents et
demi le militant lui même il ya à la
fois tous les profils vous
avec des personnes de tout âge et c'est
plutôt la volonté de s'impliquer sur le
terrain qui est la plus importante n'y a
pas d'âge pour
il existait déjà un groupe ump saint
quentin en ai vu notamment la création
du tout justement voilà vous êtes dans
une nouvelle dynamique volonté de rendre
visible cette force militante qui
existent sur le terrain de donner un
ancrage réel donc voilà c'est c'est à
cet effet que nous allons nous employer
dans les prochains mois c'est aussi le
but de préparer dans tout cas 2,2 rendre
dynamique ses troupes avant les
élections régionales
oui oui et alors
tout le monde sait que bien sûr nous
avons des échéances au mois de décembre
et la constitution de cette coordination
des des républicains de saint quentin en
yvelines a bien sûr l'adhésion de tous
les élus de saint quentin en yvelines et
notamment la première d'entre elles qui
valérie pécresse donc qui est à la fois
notre présidente de la fédération 78
élèves et qui est aussi candidate aux
élections régionales
donc effectivement nos premières actions
seront effectivement tourné vers les
élections régionales de destin l'ump qui
a changé de nom changer de statut aussi
c'était nécessaire pour aller un petit
peu plus loin que la création du groupe
de saint quentin en yvelines
il fallait changer comment vous
l'accueillez vous aussi en tant
qu'adhérente militante mais adhérentes
aussi de cette formation de l'est
républicain ce changement mais je pense
qu' il était temps aussi de changer de
passer à autre chose non pas qu'on fasse
table rase de tout ce qui a existé mais
l'ump en soi avait déjà évolué est un
acronyme qui avait évolué dans son sens
donc je pense que le fait de ce1 de
s'appeler maintenant les républicains
est une bonne chose pour l'avenir
et puis ça à l'adhésion des mythes
l'adhésion des militants des militants
qui discutent aussi pour choisir un peu
leur poulain parce qu'elle 2017 nicolas
sarkozy est ce que c'est votre candidat
par exemple
écoutez moi je suis arrivé à ce qui
était l'ump auparavant en demie
le 6 donc mon adhésion a été à ce
moment-là total pour les présidentielles
de 2007
donc voila moi je suis dans je suis dans
un parti qui pour l'instant met en place
des primaires et on verra maintenant que
le meilleur gagne
nicolas sarkozy qui disait encore
quelques semaines défendre la liberté de
débat chez les républicains dans cette
formation politique des républicains
il ya débat il ya discussion est ce que
ce sera aussi la à la vocation de ce
groupe à saint quentin en yvelines de
favoriser les échanges entre n'est dit
encore on aura effectivement des actions
de terrain puisque l'objectif est de
fédérer tous les militants de saint
quentin en yvelines mais aussi de
d'aller à la rencontre des habitants
pas seulement en période électorale mais
au quotidien de d'aller au plus proche
des réalités de la vie quotidienne et un
autre pan effectivement de notre action
ça serait de mettre en place des
ateliers de réflexion sur des sujets qui
concernent les problématiques propres à
saint quentin en yvelines mais aussi sur
des problématiques plus nationale
effectivement pour ouvrir un peu les
débats
vous parlez des problématiques propres à
saint quentin et brawn peut-être
département des yvelines
ça a changé la donne aussi aujourd'hui
toutes ces victoires de la droite de
l'ump des républicains parce qu'au
département les républicains siège seul
avec des alliés de droite et du centre
dans les communes ya eu de nombreuses
victoires également l'agglomération de
saint quentin est à droite
est ce que ça vous fait ressentir aussi
une certaine pression est ce que aussi
en créant ce ce groupe par exemple à
saint quentin ça permet de maintenir la
pression sur les élus alors dix ans les
militants regarde ce qui s'y passe
on veut toujours des échanges et des
débats le positionnement n'a à l'heure
actuelle c'est vraiment un
une coordination militante mais il est
vrai que donc c'est un soutien sans
faille
écoutez on est dans un parti on n'est
pas bien on peut discuter à l'intérieur
ce médiation au sein même du parti mais
bon là c'est un soutien effectivement
d'un soutien donc pour ce groupe des
républicains qui voient le jour à saint
quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui merci d'être passé en
plateau juste avant le lancement qui
aura lieu ce soir ce 30 juin du côté des
encours merci à vous il est question des
régionales justement à présent dans ce
set 8 politique c'est la dernière ligne
droite avant la trêve estivale les
candidats et qui multiplie les
déplacements en ile de france à
commencer par claude bartolone le
président de l'assemblée nationale têtes
de listes socialistes il était à
guyancourt et attrapes
voici une dizaine de jours il a visité
le vélodrome il a évoqué le projet de
couverture de la nationale 10 on
l'écouté nous parler de son programme en
matière d'éducation la gestion des
lycées est l'une des principales
compétences des régions
je veux vraiment que l'on puisse
réfléchir à ce que doit être
l'intervention de la région à la fois
pour bâtir et entretenir les lycées mais
aussi devenir une région qu éducative
voyez je pense vraiment que les
collectivités locales ou un rôle à jouer
parce qu'il y à l'instruction qui relève
de la responsabilité des enseignants de
l'éducation nationale
mais il y a à côté de l'instruction
aussi tout ce qui relève de l'éducation
bien entendu les parents ont un rôle
essentiel mais les collectivités locales
dans le cadre de ce qu'elles peuvent
apporter comme soutien au sport à la
culture peuvent être aussi des
collectivités qui participent à cet acte
éducative et je revendique l'idée de
renforcer le rôle de la région en termes
d'acteurs éducatifs
le ps qui pour l'instant n'a pas réussi
l'union à gauche le parti communiste
annonce lancer seul dans la campagne des
régionales son responsable pierre
laurent sera tête de liste après avoir
laissé planer le doute ces dernières
semaines s'il est élu à la tête de la
région il annonce qu'il quittera son
mandat de sénateur du côté du front
national à présent c'est vallerand de
saint-just trésorier et qui sera tête de
liste en ile-de-france il entend réunir
20 % des électeurs
là où les sondages le créditent
aujourd'hui de 10
% l'ambition entre 26 et 31 sièges
actuellement la formation ne dispose
d'aucun élu en ile de france l'ex avocat
de jean-marie le pen
elle va lancer officiellement sa
campagne fin septembre mais il a déjà
dévoilé les contours de son programme
lors d'un déplacement tout récemment à
versailles nous insisterons beaucoup sur
les questions de l'action économique de
la région et on est en train de mettre
au point un programme que je pense
originale sur la question des transports
et puis aussi et surtout ce que j'ai
appelé les quartiers délaissés c'est à
dire on connaît bien ça dans les
yvelines
mais surtout plus tôt un peu plus encore
dans le sud de l'essonne où dans l'est
de la seine-et-marne beaucoup d'endroits
où il n'y a plus de service public où il
n'y a plus de commerçants et pourtant où
il ya beaucoup de gens qui habitent et
qui se sent délaissée dans un instant je
recevrai aurélien véron il est président
du parti libéral démocrate lui aussi
tête de liste aux régionales dans notre
région mais pour le moment retour sur un
autre déplacement dans le cadre de ce
scrutin qui se tiendra en décembre
nicolas dupont aignan pour debout la
france est venue à cette semaine dans
les yvelines
il a parlé de transport premier
déplacement pour nicolas dupont-aignan
dans les yvelines le député maire de
yerres dans l'essonne tête de liste pour
debout la france l'un de ses axes de
campagne pour les régionales présentées
ce jour là les transports en commun et
les déplacements en voiture
il s'agit pas de dire que tout se fera
en voiture mais 70 % des déplacements en
ile-de-france se font aujourd'hui en
grande couronne en voiture et la
politique des écologistes qui consiste à
dire on n'investit plus à créer des
embouteillages et donc de la pollution
mais donc moi je propose qu'on
réinvestissent dans les infrastructures
routières à certains endroits précis
pour débloquer des bouchons à six mois
des élections régionales les différentes
formations sont en train de finaliser
leurs listes celle de deux vous la
france devrait être connu au mois de
septembre
vous aurez des surprises ce qui aura des
maires des yvelines des élus qu en ont
un peu assez du régime des partis soit
le clientélisme socialiste soit le
clientélisme ump moi je pense que enfin
république soit disant républicain je
pense que les français en ont marre
je le permanent entre le parti
socialiste et les anciens ump je pense
qu'il faut envoyer à la région des gens
libres indépendantes lors des régionales
de 2010 debout la france déjà mené dans
notre région par nicolas dupont aignan
avait obtenu 4 % des suffrages lui aussi
candidat tête de liste en île de france
aurélien véron bonsoir président du
parti libéral-démocrate vous êtes membre
toujours du bureau de réforme et
modernité
est ce que voulaient voir le bureau a
évolué oui j'ai toujours préféré cette
question parce que moi là parce que
c'est présidé par l'ex ump donc
républicain hervé mariton pourquoi ne
pas vous présenter avec les républicains
puisqu'on le voit vous avez des
affinités jeu des affinités personnelles
avec la rue mariton mais les
républicains ont un projet de société
qui est pas du tout du tout celui du
parti libéral le point ce temps
d'ailleurs je cherche le projet du parti
république du public 1 je vois juste des
fêtes de série cherché à monter des
écuries moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
france est à bout de souffle
le modèle social français est un modèle
qui est moribond et qui étouffe
l'entreprise qui étouffe les acteurs de
la société civile je parle des
associations je parle de la vie sociale
le lien social en train de mourir il
faut réinventer un modèle français
les républicains je les vois pas du tout
réinventer quoi que ce soit je vais vous
remettre des médailles ans la discussion
avec les républicains aucune discussion
ne trouvait pas dans la droite qui était
incarnée par les républicains dans le
centre la droite la droite qui votent la
loi renseignement qui est liberticide
qui rendent en vie privée et qui
refusent de le voir macron ce n'est pas
ma droite et le centre avec lui dit vous
en avez fait partie un temps oui je
crois que le centre aujourd'hui c'est le
parti libéral démocrate parce que le
centre n'existe plus c'est quoi un
centre c'est une formation des
formations qui ont un projet de société
qui sont au premier tour indépendant de
la droite aujourd'hui ludique qui se
prétend centriste va au premier tour
avec les républicains sans aucun projet
particulier j'appelle pas ça le sont
aujourd'hui le parti libéral oui nous
assumons cette position de centre et
nous irons premier tour sans les
républicains
on va parler de votre projet juste
aujourd'hui vous jouer gros sur ce
scrutin parce que vous n'avez pas gagné
d'élus aux élections départementales
notamment
oui on est parti il ya des régionales
millions
et on a une formation qui est né il ya
quelques années seulement 2008 à dauphin
2008 donc on a enseigné en place 2009
2010 donc c'est un parti qui est
vraiment récent c'est notre première
grosse élections on joue gros et
évidemment je sais qu'une grosse
élections mais vous savez d'île de
france et 5 milliards d'euros par an
c'est neuf mille fonctionnaires
donc c'est un gros enjeu pour les
franciliens donc les questions qu'on met
sur la table le vote fiscale la
protection contre la hausse d'impôts des
franciliens tous les ans pas de hausses
d'impôts dans leur dos chacun hausses
d'impôts de 2 validée par un référendum
ça la démocratie en continu et c'est
comme si la démocratie on continue c'est
refuser de donner un chèque en blanc à
des élus qu'on ne connaît pas parce que
si vous demandez aux gens désirent aux
habitants des yvelines qui est président
de la région ile de france
personne ne peut vous répondre donc il
s'agit parce que le nom de la pollution
devrait revenir tout de même il va
revenir à cela dit va disparaître
puisque c'est il y aura un volet
national qui a vieux qui nous assaillent
apparatchiks des parties prend sa relève
donc moi j'attends juste que la région
elles soient responsables tous les ans
devant les franciliens de leur argent
c'est notre argent contribuables on doit
savoir où il va et si on monte les
impôts faisons voter les franciliens
chaque année ça veut dire que chaque
année vous organiser un référendum
la grèce le fait en une semaine pourquoi
l'île de france 2 ce matin en une
semaine ont 15 jours chaque année
si le budget déficitaire vous fait
valider par les franciliens sinon ils
ont l'obligation de baisser leurs
dépenses publiques comme les ménages le
font tous les mois lorsque leurs
salaires sont restreints lorsque les
impôts monte c'est eux qui seraient
serrent la ceinture et bien demain c'est
la région de serrer la ceinture
vous voulez aussi ouvrir à la
concurrence dont les services publics
avec une offre plus étoffée en matière
de transports aussi je veux un vrai
marché des transports publics
quand vous voyez que hubert le cab le
blabla car le covoiturage ya une vraie
révolution dans les transports
individuels
cette révolution elle n'attend qu'une
chose pour se développer des transports
collectifs c'est qu'on libère ce marché
tant qu'on est dans le libéralisme à
outrance et aucun contrôle ya plus
d'intervention il y à 1 stif 1 syndicat
des transports d'île de france qui a des
vrais pouvoirs ce qui est haletant
devant le bayer on le laisse on garde la
trame actuelle ratp ou sncf qu'on met
sous concession avec une délégation de
service public avec des vrais
prestataire de service pour avoir de la
qualité de la fiabilité des horaires
respectés et puis tout ce qui est ouvert
tout le reste c'est libre ouvert à la
concurrence
vous aurez des blablas bus potel des
services de bus internet vous vous
inscrivez vous avez un intérêt entre
deux villes dit
des yvelines qui sont grands
départements vous n'avez pas de service
public aujourd'hui qui vous transporte
demain vous aurez peut-être un navette
qui se mettrait en place à vous coûtera
1,2 euro laissons le marché proposé des
tas de solutions
nous voulons être des clients et plus
des usagers mais sans contrôle sans
réglementation sans législation comme
les vtc il ya désagréments il ya des il
faut des permis les assurances sa vague
arbitres même un regard sur ce qui se
fait le syndicat des transports d'île de
france le stif garde un regard il faut
avoir son agrément parce qu'il faut des
minimums de sécurité évidemment mais un
marché c'est comme les vtc hubert
aujourd'hui explose littéralement le cab
entreprises françaises et partout dans
les grandes villes
il n'y a pas de raison dans le too l'île
de france on n'est pas des bus réactif
qui répondent aux besoins des
franciliens
je continue à regarder un petit peu les
points de programme que vous avez
développé jusqu'à présent vous voulez
appliquer les patrons aussi dans votre
campagne
ce soit des pme et des tpe on les entend
pas assez ils sont pas assez impliqués
représenter notre liste sera très
représentés par des entrepreneurs donc
des gens qui savent gérer un budget qui
savent aussi manager des équipes qui
savent innover et je crois que les gens
ont leur place dans la politique et qui
ont essayé sur la droite par exemple qui
ont été horriblement déçu par la droite
et même trahi mais vous savez moi les
salariés que je rencontre ont été aussi
traduit par la droite mais il faut avoir
des compétences de gestion il faut des
compétences de service parce que les
franciliens encore une fois ce sont pas
juste des matricules qui payent des
impôts aveuglément ce sont des français
qui veulent des retours sur
investissement ils veulent être
actionnaire de l'île de france nous
proposons aux franciliens d'être les
actionnaires de leur région c'est à dire
qu'ils ont des comptes la région a des
comptes à rendre et des vrais services à
offrir et je pense que des entrepreneurs
qui ont sens des responsabilités le sens
du service vont certainement améliorer
la qualité des services produits par
l'ile-de-france qui sont aujourd'hui
très décevant avec une maîtrise des
dépenses
on n'engage pas de nouvelles dépenses
évidemment les dépenses est d'abord
notre argent votre argent c'est notre
argent à tous
on peut pas le dépensé inconsidérément
on veut des benchmark
on veut des retours sur investissement
on veut de la qualité en selle et 400
vide aussi qu'il faut faire des
économies la dette a monté de 50 % en
cinq ans les impôts locaux montent et 35
% en cinq ans c'est la grèce eh bien
nous ne voulons pas que les de france
plonge comme la grèce ou en guilde
françois la hauteur il ya des enjeux qui
sont des enjeux de l'innovation de
campus universitaires d'entreprise de
mud écosystèmes pour avoir la croissance
et de l'emploi à la clé manifestement
les hauts fonctionnaires qui gers a
sonné à parapsy que j'appelle ça des
apparatchiks parce que l'intégralité de
leur carrière a été fait dans la
fonction publique nous voulons des gens
qui connaissent le secteur privé ça
arie entrepreneurs du monde associatif
qui savent aussi ce que c'est que le
lien social autrement que des
fonctionnaires tous ces gens doivent
irriguer la région donc il faut
renouveller les têtes c'est le projet du
parti libéral-démocrate et les économies
en effet où vous restez ces économies où
les familles dans la bureaucratie neuf
mille fonctionnaires c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup de strates qui sont assez
inutile c'est beaucoup de saupoudrage
clientéliste beaucoup de subventions aux
associations qui sont pas justifiées
c'est une transparence rare existantes
on parlait de l'association des cannes
par exemple aller sur le site de la
région vous verrez le montant qui est
allouée vous verrez bien aucune
justification il ya 70 pages de non vous
avez juste un nom d'association
moi je voudrais une justification je
suis comme vous je vous pose beaucoup de
questions je suis candidat je vais
attendre déposé un oui mais qu'elle est
associée à ce jeune de trouver des noms
que je n'ai pas trouvé la justification
moi je veux juste qu'on justifie
éventuellement que nous et parler d'eux
et en subventions mais juste comprendre
pourquoi ya ces subventions hasard une
raison vous irez vous irez sur le compte
d'une entreprise cotée en bourse et vous
irez sur le compte de l'île de france il
y en a une qui est transparente c'est le
leur trouver du cac 40 n'est pas
forcément un modèle métier transparente
vous avez des comptes de la région n'y a
rien comme information en temps
contribuables ça me choque les droits de
l'homme oblige toute administration à de
la rendre des comptes et être
transparent je veux rétablir cette
transparence
elle n'existe pas nous allons assurer et
vous parlez de faire des économies avec
les différents échelons le département
où suppriment aussi par exemple quel
regard vous allez sur le développement
de la région mais là sur un plus long
terme sur les dix quinze vingt
prochaines années
aujourd'hui faudrait une grande région
qui dirige tout avec des agglomérations
un petit peu qu'ils des regroupements
d'agglomération puis pas de grand paris
nous voulons fusionner le grand paris
avec la région parce que le grand paris
je vous rappelle ses 348 élus
supplémentaires au moment où par
d'enlever des strates c'est quand même
étrange 348 élus qui seront payés entre
4000 et 5000 500 euros par mois
autant de chauffeur un palais qui va
falloir construire des dorures de la
république supplémentaires tout ça c'est
pas possible la région doit avoir un
vrai rôle et les départements le joue
aujourd'hui avec des intercommunalités
qui marche très bien
ça n'a plus beaucoup de chance le
département ça relève pas de la région
paca on peut pas effacer d'un coup de
baguette magique des départements le
gouvernement s'était engagé et moi je
soutenais cet aspect du projet de loi de
notre de la réforme de territoire ça a
été retirée malheureusement mais je
reste convaincu que le département
aujourd'hui est périmée avec des
agglomérations plus grande que ce qui
existe aujourd'hui
il y avait un projet et quelques temps
en agglomération autour de 51 ans n'est
venu jusqu'à 800 milles
tu en sais quelque chose les textes
l'europe la presse et aux municipalités
de s'arranger c'est la démocratie cumul
a fonctionné moi je suis méfiant
vis-à-vis des grandes agglomérations
plus ça grossit plus on perd en
transparence et plus il ya de cooptation
et moins il ya de concurrence
moi je pense que les services publics ce
sont des vrais services a décidé de la
concurrence de la transparence et
peut-être des petites structures des
plus petites structures
huit cent mille de personnes les
parisiens ont deux millions deux cent
mille personnes sur la structure paris
c'est lourd à gérer je peux vous dire
que c'est ça pose beaucoup de soucis
donc président du parti libéral tête de
liste en ile-de-france y aura beaucoup
de listes qui seront présentées à
travers la france juste à notre ambition
c'est six listes pour l'instant on en a
deux qui sont lancés 4 qui travaillent
et concernant l'île de france est ce que
la liste est terminée est ce que nous on
n'est pas terminée parce que nous avons
des contacts de beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
de salariés l'associatif et puis d'élus
locaux qui sont intéressés surtout quand
il ya plus de centres il le centre en
train de reconstruire et bien en
j'entends des élus locaux à me contacter
pour me demander où on va et si ça nous
les inégalités et moderne de toutes les
formations des gens sans aucune
étiquette qui se posent la question de
2010 elle parce que des régionales c'est
aussi la préparation 2017
préparez déjà les législatives aussi moi
je crois que ces territoires régionaux
c'est important et ça prépare
effectivement l'élection suivante
une dernière question d'ambition c'est
combien de % quatre salles ambitions
assez d'être l'ambition rêver c'est
d'être second tour et c'est être élu
pourquoi pas c'est pour ça qu'on est
candidat au sénat elle pas pour être sur
un strapontin et avoir un revenu parce
que ça c'est pas du tout intéressant
c'est d'avoir un strapontin pour peser
sur les décisions c'est l'orientation
donc si on est en capacité de négocier
d'être second tour nous serons au second
tour mais sinon vous négocierait donc
avec le avec la droite 65% on verra mais
sait on négociera pas si le projet n'est
pas repris nous on est au effaré
aujourd'hui par le manque de démocratie
on est effaré par des services publics
qui sont des monopoles insalubres au
quotidien donc nous négocierons si le
projet avance mais nous n'excluons pas
d'être au second tour est ouvert
aujourd'hui les français sont écoeurés
par la vie politique ancienne ça fait 40
ans que les choses n'ont pas changé nous
apportons une offre nouvelle
rafraîchissante avec des idées qui sont
précises concrètes
je suis sûr que nous aurons un
enthousiasme populaire rendez vous à la
rentrée mais vous verrez la campagne
sera pleine de surprises merci aurélien
véron président a donc à tête de liste
du parti libéral-démocrate merci à vous
avant de refermer ce numéro je vous
donne rendez vous ce mardi soir ce 30
juin sur téléphiles à 21h45 pour la 1re
div
du café politique je recevrai sandrine
gambe responsable fédéral du parti
socialiste elle vient d'être investi
tête de liste yvelines aux régionales
écoutez cet extrait de son entretien
vous êtes personnes pas mal fédération
socialiste en ile de france
comment ça s'explique le parti
socialiste a du mal à se féminiser la
vie politique en général et pas facile
pour les femmes même si beaucoup de
faits et je vais vraiment je pense que
si la gauche avait pas été au pouvoir on
n'en serait pas là puisque toutes les
lois de parité toutes les lois qui
permettait plus de représentativité des
femmes se sont à chaque fois les
gouvernements de causes qui les ont
portés mais c'est un travail sur le long
terme
et puis c'est vrai que on essaye de
changer mais les réunions politiques
c'est le soir donc pour une vie
familiale c'est compliqué
comment vous êtes accueilli par vos
homologues hommes masculin jamais je
n'ai jamais ressenti devant apprennent
par le passé aujourd'hui peut-être moins
on parle facilement via je n'ai jamais
ressenti de problème de ce côté-là
après ses exploits parfois que le noyage
me soit un petit peu le seul le café
politique a retrouvé à dès ce soir sur
l'antenne de téléphiles sandrine grands
groupes qui vient donc d'être désignée
tête de liste dans les yvelines pour le
parti socialiste à noter que benoît un
nom sera lui aussi candidat aux
régionales en île de france le député
des yvelines est deuxième sur cette
liste départementales et donc en
position largement éligibles même en cas
d'échec de la gauche c'est la fin de
cette édition du 7 8 politique
rendez vous en septembre pour de
nouveaux numéros très bonnes vacances je
vous retrouve en tout cas jusqu'au 10
juillet pour le journal quotidien sur
téléphiles très bonne soirée